safety on the Las Vegas Strip for
America's party a top priority for our
Law Enforcement Officers good evening to
you thank you for joining us at five I'm
Brian Loftus I'm Vanessa Murphy officers
from the valley joining many other
agencies across the country to compare
ideas Victoria Saha joining us now live
from the strip on what we can expect on
New Year's Eve Victoria
yeah New Year's Eve the strip behind me
will be packed with people ready to
party but as we've been receiving that
danger can be anywhere so our law
enforcement and security officers are
gearing up to get ahead of the game
here we go it's going off New Year's Eve
a night where the glitz and Glam take
over the Las Vegas Strip
and while you are ringing in the new
year law enforcement and security
officers will have their eyes and ears
everywhere our officers are working very
closely with our Casino Partners to
ensure that again everybody is safe
throughout the strip Jonathan Alvarez a
CEO of
National is
a ton of friends it's not only an
investment in our officers but I believe
that bringing ourselves and everyone who
joins in it's an investment in our
communities his team will be one of the
many security officers on the strip on
New Year's Eve one guy was strike then
he'll strike and defend one of the key
components of this conference was to
learn de-escalation tactics looking get
your butt handed to you basically is not
being prepared for the surprise attack
the Night comes out Nick is going to
respond Trump did a ground learning from
other metropolitan area officers to see
what methods our law enforcement could
apply in southern Nevada they have split
seconds to make decisions The Wider
their knowledge base is the more
informed that decision is going to be
and for our viewers and at home if you
come across a situation where you need
to protect yourself I learned a couple
of tips starts out inside one hand
over here using your arms and elbows to
find yourself an opening to where you
can fight back good job this hand there
will be elbow and bring this hand back
now right there oh
another bit of advice I got is to have
situational awareness I know we all love
taking the pictures and the Selfies but
put down that phone time to time and
just look around you Victoria Saha eight
news now
America's party returns in a little
under two weeks already this year's
theme is let's go big